Hello everyone
so right now the pre boards season is going on so
I you like it student my B like I am
feeling very bad rate so gas I am here
help you out I will be giving you some
tips about you attempt the paper in  D
Pre Board Examination You Begin With
First Point Is Read The Questions Carefully Read Them These
Or Thrice Second
Point Is Complete The Paper Before 15
Minutes So That You Can Have Sufficient Time To
Go Through D Answer Which Of Already
Attempted Third Point Is Please Aate Tu  The
Word Limit Don't Write You Know Such In Every
Question Don Do Date Right And Next
Last Point Is Take Proper Rest Take Proper Sleep
And Don't Take Stress All D
Best By By